I've been using this new website called
Project 100 where you can basically
share ideas about topics that are
interesting to you and it was created
for people around the world who want to
share ideas about a whole bunch of
different topics and I'll actually show
you what some of these topics are to
give you a sense of what I'm talking
about here we're talking about anything
from activism animals arts literature
peace race society sports statistics
work the internet I mean it is really
really broad ranging and the idea is
that all of the posts ideas articles
videos images everything is coming from
the community from community members and
there are note gatekeepers at all this
is a website where whatever community
members want to post gets posted so i
actually did one all sort of walk you
through what I did first thing I did was
I had to uh first sign up on the website
super easy very easy to sign up I'm
guessing by this point if you're even
watching this clip you're probably
pretty familiar with how to sign up on
website so that was really really easy
once signed up I then went in to share
an idea and as you can see you basically
set the title and tags for your idea you
said a category for it and you can
upload media to it so what I did was I
uploaded my uh graphic and I was
actually sharing a story about Hillary
Clinton's comment on fifty percent of
Donald Trump's um followers being
deplorable and I submitted the video
that we did I submitted a graphic that
we did and then I hit the preview button
which showed me what you're looking at
right now this is sort of my story my
idea as shared and after previewing it I
actually was able to publish it to the
project 100 website and people were able
to say I like this I don't like it
commentary etc and what's really really
cool about this is that number one ideas
can be posted using text video images
or any combination thereof and then
through a voting system users can vote
for the ideas that they think deserve a
spot on the 2016 project 100 list which
will feature the top ideas of all of the
ideas submitted to the project 100
website so i encourage you to go to the
website project 100 dot org that's all
spelled out in words not with numbers
project 100 dot org sign up host an idea
email them to us if you've done them and
we'll check out some of the ideas that
came from our audience it's cool i'm on
there i'm voting i'm submitting ideas i
love it